Optimal at this altitude,
I can run flat out for a half mile before my hands start shaking.
No one else will be posting a question.
Now
I'm a cybernetic organism living.
This episode is brought to you by fresh books,
man.
Oh Man.
Do a lot of listeners to this podcast and readers of mine love fresh books to
the extent that I ended up meeting with the CEO not very long ago.
Why are they so popular?
Well,
they are the number one cloud accounting software designed exclusively for self
employed professionals.
That's many of you and used by more than 10 million people.
You can send invoices,
track your time,
and get paid very,
very quickly,
which suits the needs of a lot of freelancers,
a lots of Antoine vose and beyond.
You can't take pictures of receipts.
You can link your credit card and debit card,
so all the things you buy automatically appear in your fresh books in the right
category,
so on and so forth.
Makes taxes easy,
makes invoices easy.
It makes your life easier.
And also in fact,
I'd recommend a pdf.
Uh,
they didn't ask me to read this part by the way.
They'd put the other pdf awhile back called breaking the time barrier subtitle,
how to unlock your true earning potential so you can search for breaking the
time barrier.
A lot of people ask me,
how can I get a four hour work week with a service business and the story in
that Ebook,
it's pdf is the short answer is really,
really good.
So I think you should also check that out.
So breaking the time error,
checking out,
but also why not test out freshbooks.
Claim your 30 day unrestricted free trial@freshbooks.com forward slash Tim and
enter Tim Ferriss,
two r's and two s's in the how did you hear about us section?
That sounds like we're going to get very little tracking and it's a lot of work,
but just go to freshbooks.com forward slash Tim and tried out because it is a
very good product and I think you will find it simplifies your life in joy.
This episode is brought to you by me undies.
I've spent the last few years wearing underwear from these guys,
24 seven or close to it outside of showers and sexy time and swimming and they
are the most comfortable and colorful underwear I've ever owned.
You just check out the camouflage boxer briefs.
I'm a big fan.
Me undies are designed in La and made from sustainably sourced micro Madell.
What's that?
It is a fabric of three times softer than cotton.
Trust me.
Try it out.
You'll understand why I wear these so much.
If underwear isn't your thing though,
like I would imagine everyone wears underwear,
but if it isn't your thing,
Mandy is also makes socks.
Their socks are spun from premium material,
making them just as comfortable as the underwear.
Now,
right now,
[inaudible] has an exclusive offer just for Tim Ferriss show listeners.
You can get 20% off your first order and free shipping,
so check it out.
Take a look.
Some of them are pretty Rad.
They have different cereals from your childhood on underwear and a lot more
[inaudible] dot com forward slash.
Tim Take a look at [inaudible] dot com forward slash.
Tim,
they offer a 100% satisfaction guarantee.
If you're unhappy with your purchase for any reason,
just send them back and you receive a full refund.
Again,
that's me,
undies.com forward slash Tim for 20% off and free shipping.
Hello,
boys and girls,
ladies and germs.
This is Tim Ferriss and welcome to another episode of the Tim Ferriss Show where
each episode is my job to deconstruct world class performers from all different
spheres of life,
arenas of competition.
This time around it is entrepreneurship business in just general awesomeness.
We have Arianna Huffington.
You can find her on Twitter at Ariana hough and elsewhere.
Of course on the socials.
She has been named to time magazines,
list of the world's 100 most influential people in Forbes.
Most powerful women list originally from Greece.
She moved to England when she was 16 and graduated from Cambridge with an Emmy
and economics.
In May,
2005 she launched the Huffington Post,
a news and blog side.
They quickly became one of the most widely read linked to and frequently cited
media brands on the Internet.
And in 2012 won a Pulitzer Prize for national reporting in August,
2016 she wants you to thrive global with the mission of ending the stress and
burnout epidemic by offering companies and individual sustainable science based
solutions to wellbeing.
Ariana serves on a lot of boards including Uber and the Center for public
integrity.
And she's the author of 15 what,
15 books,
including her most recent thrive subtitle,
the third metric to redefining success and creating a life of wellbeing,
wisdom and wonder.
And the sleep revolution.
Subtitle,
transforming your life one night at a time.
This is a very wide ranging conversation.
We get into plenty of tactics.
She has a any,
an expert storyteller and very,
very funny to boot.
So I hope you enjoy this as much as I did.
So without further ado,
here is my conversation with Arianna Huffington.
Ariana,
welcome to the show.
Thank you team.
Uh,
I love your podcast and I'm really happy to be part of it.
Well,
I have had so much fun interacting with you over the years and also observing
you in environments where you get to ask a lot of questions.
So I'm happy to have the chance to turn the tables and actually dig into your
story because you're always highlighting people around you.
And now it's my chance to turn it around and dig into a lot of the background
that I haven't heard.
But I wanted to start with a question about breakfast because we did it as a
sound check.
I think people will enjoy it.
So what did you have for breakfast this morning?
So,
um,
every morning I have coffee,
bulletproof coffee for breakfast,
which is basically as you know,
eh coffee who is the um,
organic butter.
And then I don't really like breakfast in terms of food.
Um,
I,
I was brought up in Greece and people don't have breakfast,
they have coffee and I'm so like a good Greek peasant girl.
I don't really eat until lunch time.
And if you want to know what's my favorite food at lunchtime,
it's breakfast
at lunch.
What is your go to?
My go to lunch is poached eggs.
Scrambled eggs are boiled eggs or any kind of breakfast food.
You,
you have,
we're going to come back to all of your experimentation because you seem to have
tried just about everything,
but I want to give people just a taste perhaps.
I mean,
you've tried firewalking list-making journal keeping infrared Saunas at your
very game to experiment.
And I'm curious to know if there are any particular practices like those that
have,
have stuck with you,
that you've found continually valuable for you.
And it could be part of your daily routine or it could be some type of object.
Could be anything.
So the bottom of my daily routine that actually started when I was 13 and which
is 3000 years ago.
And I,
I can't say I've done it consistently every day since,
but I have,
um,
in the last few years done,
it consistently is meditating.
So I tried to do it right after I wake up,
before I engage in my day.
And,
um,
and it's been absolutely amazing in terms of,
how much peace and strength and joy,
it's a broad me,
um,
as I go through my day,
no matter what the challenges and problems and,
um,
I've tried other things which I do intermittently but not every day like a
writing down my dreams.
There are periods in my life when I wrote down my dreams every day and I have
like,
um,
massive notebooks with my dreams.
Um,
and now I do it,
um,
sporadically,
but I still keep a pen by my bed.
That's one of those bands that light in the night.
So you don't have to turn on the light because as you know,
um,
the less,
intrusion of outside life,
you have the more details of your dream,
you remember.
So you have a pen that has a light on the front of it?
Yeah.
Yes.
I've never,
I'm amazed that I've never seen such a thing.
Okay.
I'm sending you one.
I will.
I will definitely try that.
And I want to dig into the details of the meditation practice for a second.
What type of meditation do you practice or what does a session look like for
you?
So I have tried every kind of meditation as you,
as you kind of already announced.
You know,
I love experimenting.
So at first when I was 13,
I was,
believe it or not,
um,
initiated into transcendental meditation by Maharishi himself who happened to be
nothing's Greece.
And I was this 13 year old girl Maya,
who is very eccentric mother who was doing yoga and meditating and had convinced
my sister and me that it will meditated.
We will be better at school.
And since I was determined to get great grades,
I thought this would help me.
That is incredible.
I had no idea.
So you've called your mother a hero before.
I've heard this and how we were going to dig into some of the lessons that you
learned for from her.
I'd like to hear about that,
but how,
how did you end up getting in front of Maharishi and being inducted in that way?
How did that come together?
Oh,
she sounded shame.
She was kind of amazing.
She,
she could make anything happen.
And,
um,
I don't know how she found out what he would be and how she got her daughter's
there and,
but that's what happened.
And at that time,
I didn't frankly think it was a big deal.
I have seen some also together with my two daughters who are now 26 and 28,
been reintroduced a transcendental meditation by Bob Roth,
who is at a fabulous teacher here in New York.
But also in the meantime,
I have practiced many other kinds of,
um,
many other kinds of meditation,
you know,
Buddhist Meditation,
compassion,
Meditation,
and also meditation,
um,
taught by John Roger,
you know,
who started the movement for spiritual inner awareness.
So I am,
I basically date with a tone,
but focusing very much on my breath.
You know,
the,
the inhalation and exhalation is just a big part of my meditation.
And
on an everyday basis I do half an hour,
but over the weekend or whatever,
I can,
uh,
I made one hour,
I may do two hours.
And the other thing that is great team is that if I wake up in the middle of the
night for whatever reason and I have trouble going back to sleep,
let Sam particularly stressed overthinking something,
I'm on a plane,
I'm jet lagged,
whatever.
I just never worry about it anymore.
I just say,
this is amazing.
I have unlimited time to meditate.
Right?
You were,
you were gifted,
gifted tire or whatever it might be.
Yes,
and normally you know when,
when it happens,
it's like three in the morning or which is a calling to the Dalai Lama,
the optimal time to meditate.
I think,
hey,
the Dalai Lama and I are meditating now and it's very clear,
you know,
all the new science on sleep shows that Eh,
something which an experiment,
which they call paradoxical intention,
that if you take two groups of people and you tell one group to try and go back
to sleep and another group to stay awake,
the group that you do,
whom you said stairway falls asleep faster.
That's funny.
Right?
It's like,
it's just one of those things where the key is to try it less,
not to try it.
Exactly.
Especially around sleep because sleep is about surrender and trying to Saranda
is really hard.
It is hard.
I think it's especially,
especially hard for type a personalities.
But you mentioned that your mother could make anything happen and you also
mentioned that you were,
seemed at least driven to get very good grades.
Uh,
where did that,
where did that desire to get good grades come from?
Um,
I don't really know where that came from,
but I,
I was a venture of awkward kid.
I was ridiculously tall for a Greek girl and I was literally five feet 10 when I
was 13 years old and that they must of my classmates were five feet,
nothing.
So I was literally tiring all over them.
I was in a girls' school.
And um,
just to give you an idea of how bad that was,
eh,
I was excluded from the school parade
cheese.
Well,
they had the,
you know,
the tallest girls because I was too tall and I would stick out too much.
So I also had very frizzy hair and wore glasses.
And so I just really spent a lot of time just reading and studying.
Um,
rather than having a lot of friends and being social.
Okay,
well we're going to bounce around on the timeline a bit.
So that's just how my mind works.
I'm surprised to hear that because you are one of the most,
if not the most socially adept person I've ever seen live.
I mean it's really like watching,
you know,
Tom Brady playing football or something to watch you navigate and manage a room.
I'm not kidding.
It's really impressive.
I mean,
when I've been at say dinners with you,
just observing how you weave everyone together is as enjoyable to me as the
conversations that I have.
So how did you learn to be social?
Well,
Tim,
it's kind of interesting because I know it's hard to believe,
but I'm,
I am an introvert and there isn't,
I know that is that I have experienced every emotion in my life,
including rage and fear and disappointment,
one and everything you can imagine.
But I have never experienced loneliness.
I need time alone.
And I long for time alone and I've never said that this is too much time alone.
So I think that's a pretty good indication that I'm fundamentally an introvert
who loves people.
Um,
provided I have enough time to refuel by myself.
And if I do,
then I love,
I love bringing people together.
I think that's one of the things I most love is kind of introducing my friends
to each other and making sure that connecting,
um,
setting people are
numerous ways to really,
um,
make sure that people I care about are connected to each other.
Okay.
So I want to be putting the pieces together slowly.
Kind of like the movie memento,
if anybody listening gets that.
But what took you,
I know that we're,
we're jumping around,
but I'm sort of following the scent as we go.
Uh,
what led you to move to the UK?
So again,
um,
that's another mother's story because I saw in a magazine at picture of
Cambridge University
and I absolutely fell in love with it.
I have no idea why.
And I said to my mother with absolute conviction,
I want to go there.
And everybody else.
I said that to my dad.
My friends said,
don't be ridiculous.
You can't go there.
Um,
how old were you at the time?
I was,
um,
14.
Okay.
Got It.
And,
um,
they all said you have no,
you don't speak English.
We have now my name and it's hard even for English girls to get into Cambridge.
So forget about that.
And My mother said,
okay,
let's find out how you can get to Canberra,
which I'm sure we can make that happen.
And uh,
so she found out that I could take my,
what they call gcs,
general certificate of education,
which you needed to get at.
And I've,
you still do to get into English universities from the British Council,
but then I would have to take a special Cambridge exam that I could apply for a
scholarship.
And,
um,
of course I immediately started learning English.
Up until then I had learned French because in,
uh,
in Greece a French was the official language at the time,
the official foreign language.
So I had learned French at school,
immediately started learning English.
And,
um,
to cut a long story short,
I got a scholarship into Cambridge and definitely that would never have happened
without my mother saying,
let's make that happen.
She even said to me one day,
you know,
God has this really cheap tickets and we can go and see Cambridge,
not see anybody at Cadbury's,
just go see it.
It was like an early form of visualization.
So she and I,
she and I was really flew to London,
took a train to Cambridge and just walked around and made it real for me.
And,
um,
and that was her,
that was how she was.
And uh,
so let me just make sure I understand this.
She took you to Cambridge so you could walk around Cambridge feeling like you
already part of it.
Is that the exemption?
Exactly.
Wow.
I did.
Do you find that helpful for you?
It just made it,
very rarely took it from a magazine picture to every El Place where we walked
around for hours and,
and saw the different colleges and had 'em coffee in the coffee shop.
And so the river and,
and of course by the end of it I wanted to go to Cambridge more than ever.
Hmm.
Is,
are there any particular parenting approaches or sayings that you use with your
daughters that your mother used with you?
Has It,
has her parenting style influenced how you parent
completely?
Um,
my parenting style is identical except um,
I'm perpetually guilty because I'm definitely not as good as she was.
And you know,
in any case,
I think most mothers are guilty about something,
especially working mothers.
They say you take the baby out and they put the guilt in.
But for me,
I think the heart of it is unconditional.
Um,
that was really her biggest gift to love you unconditionally while at the same
time making you believe that you could do anything you wanted to try,
but that if you failed,
not a problem because as she used to say,
that was one of her favorite sayings.
Failure is not the opposite of success.
It's a stepping stone to success.
So she made my sister and me feel very comfortable with failing.
It does not a big deal.
Taking risks was part of life and,
and failing was part of life.
And,
and then she was very funny and she used to say angels fly because they take
themselves seriously and um,
and whatever happened,
bad things happening.
She just literally bad things or bad,
bad things,
bad,
bad things like my file father being a philanderer and her ending ending up
separating from him,
they never actually got divorced.
Um,
how she turned that around and still managed to create an amazingly warm loving
home for us.
Or little things like our favorite thing for our birthdays was to go with her to
two movies and a play and a,
so we're ready to leave our apartment with my sister and we locked our keys in
so every other mother would have just kind of dropped the program and try to get
the keys,
et cetera.
My mother said,
okay,
no problem,
lets us God with the movies and go to the play.
Let's keep to our schedule and we'll figure it out.
And,
um,
of course by the time we are opposite the fire station.
So when we got back she went to the fire station and asked if they could help
us.
And because she was always such a giver,
she would always bring everybody food and uh,
help them with anything they wanted.
The firefighters put up a ladder up and let us in through the window.
So it seems like I'd be just by watching your mother and experiencing that,
that over time you'd,
you'd feel like you could figure out just about anything.
I mean,
just seeing someone being that adaptable I would think would,
would really impact you.
I mean the,
the question that I've been wanting to ask also about a few of these things.
You mentioned the,
the failure as a stepping stone and so on.
You,
you talked about not speaking when you saw this picture of Cambridge in a
magazine,
but I read that you became really determined to excel in the debate society at
Cambridge.
I don't know if that's accurate or not,
but if it is,
can you,
can you walk us through your decision to do that and what you were thinking at
the time?
Because I would imagine that would be very intimidating.
Yeah.
So actually what happened is that I was absolutely fascinated by debates at
Cambridge.
I love them more than anything at Cambridge.
And I was determined to learn,
to speak,
you know,
to learn to speak publicly.
And so I would literally
stay at every debate until the bitter end.
Um,
and I would wait my turn to be called on to speak because they would have the
main speakers and then anybody could,
could speak.
But I was terrible and I had a very heavy accent,
even heavier than now.
And so I was normally big glass,
like on a midnight,
but it didn't matter.
I just sat there and made notes.
I learned.
And,
um,
but I hadn't really thought of a competing too to be elected to an office at the
union that seemed like,
um,
not something I could ever achieve.
So what happened is that one weekend,
um,
when I was in London,
a friend of mine put me down for the election to the standing committee,
which was like the first step before you became a secretary and the vice braised
and then the price then.
And um,
I was deeply embarrassed when I found out.
I thought I would be humiliated and I tried to get my name off it,
but it was too late.
The balance and be brilliant.
And then do my m man surprise.
Aye.
I was elected to the top of the standing committee who just a complete surprise.
I would really never ever,
ever have guessed that this would happen.
But that's how I ended up,
you know,
then being elected secretary and vice,
but vice president and then president.
So the,
the decision to learn to speak was very,
very deliberate.
Them the five got,
I ended up becoming president of the union,
which conceptually it was a defining moment in terms of my career was completely
accidental and dependent on,
on this friend of mine who took matters into her own hands.
Why was it a defining moment for you?
Why do you think that's a defining moment?
Because,
um,
it's hard to,
to understand how much at that time it meant to be elected president of the
union.
Uh,
there was this kind of mythical,
um,
place that the Oxford and Cambridge Uni,
I'm just have a in,
in the history of England,
you know,
that's a big deal.
I visited campus once and walked through the hallways.
It's a very,
very big deal.
And you were the,
I guess the first foreign and only the third female,
is that right?
Yeah.
Yes.
And,
um,
and so what happened is that when I was elected,
it was,
it was like front page news.
It's hard to,
it's hard to,
we live in,
but like the times and the Guardian,
they had front page pictures of me on them.
There's this thrown that,
the price and sits on.
And um,
and I was invited to do every show you can imagine.
And,
and that's,
uh,
when in the course of one of the debates that I was speaking at as president,
and we just televised because a lot of the debates were televised,
um,
a publisher and saw that he obeyed and asked me to write a book based on the
views are expressed in the debates.
So truly was defining because I had no intention of being a writer.
Sounds like everything that happened to me was not in,
uh,
but,
so I,
I got this letter from Raj Davis Point and we're just actually published Germain
Greer's book,
the female eunuch.
And he asked me if I would write a book expressing the views that I had
expressed in the,
in the debate.
And I wrote back and I said,
I can't write.
And he said,
can you have lunch?
And,
and he took me to lunch and offered me a modest advance and he said,
if you,
if it turns out you can't write or I'll have lost,
I think it was 6,000 pounds for a year.
So,
um,
if,
and otherwise,
he said,
I will publish the book.
And that was my first book.
It changed the trajectory of my career because I had just gotten into the
Kennedy School of government to do a postgraduate degree there,
which I,
um,
I dropped in order to,
to write the book.
What was,
what was that first book?
What was the title?
The title was the female woman and um,
the message of the book,
what was really,
um,
very matter of fact now because it was the fact,
my believe that women should be given equal respect for whatever they choose to
do in their lives.
If they choose to have a career,
everything should be open to them.
If they choose to be mothers and they can afford to do so and not have a career,
they should be given equal respect for that.
Now that now seems like no big deal.
At the time it was very controversial because it was at the eras published in
1973.
I was 23 years and at the time it was at the moment,
at the height of what was known as the Women's Liberation Movement when only
career women
were respected.
You know,
if you chose and you are able to financially,
um,
not to have a career,
uh,
you are kind of dismissed as I'm having succumb to social conditioning or the
patriarchy.
And,
um,
and I interviewed a lot of women who made a lot of difficult choices.
Like they decide when I remember a woman saying,
I haven't had a new code for,
um,
three years,
but I want to bring up my children myself and then I can get back into the
workplace.
So I wasn't saying that one choice was better than another,
but that part of equality was equal respect for whatever choices women made.
You've had so many opportunities to interact with so many people who you could
potentially guide or mentor.
And just given that we're somewhat on the subject,
I mean,
if you were looking at one piece of that equation,
so you're looking at the,
the professional choice going into the business world.
Is,
is the advice you would give a young man or young woman the same or is there
different advice that you would give to young women who are considering really
focusing on,
uh,
charging headfirst into the business world world?
Oh,
I'm absolutely,
I'm the same advice.
Um,
the only thing that's different for women if they want to have children is,
um,
do be aware of that.
I mean,
now of course women can freeze the rags,
so it gives them a longer timeline for becoming mothers or they can choose to
adopt.
Um,
so that's great because it gives women more flexibility.
But,
um,
I think the most important thing is to do really be honest with yourself.
I mean,
I would not have been happy if I had not had,
um,
my work.
I knew that was very important to me and I actually have never not worked.
Um,
and also would not have been happy if I had not had children.
But I have many friends of mine who,
um,
don't want children and they're perfectly happy.
So I,
that's why I'm saying this is very individual and all that matters is to be
ruthlessly honest with ourselves and,
and basically making sure that the life we're following is the life we are for
ourselves rather than the life that,
um,
has been,
uh,
chosen for us by society,
our parents and friends.
Yeah.
Nike.
Now you have told us about one defining moment,
which was this,
uh,
this appointment I guess on the throne and everything that came out of that.
If,
if we then look forward after that,
what,
what would you consider the next sort of defining moment or defining decision,
uh,
in your life or the next that comes to mind for you?
Oh,
I could say then Max defining decision was deciding to leave this man that I was
very much in love with that,
eh,
because he didn't want to have children.
And by then I was 30.
I had been with him since I was 23 for seven years.
He was twice my age and half my size.
Uh,
he was,
uh,
an amazing writer.
His name is Bernard Levin,
and he was a great column raised for the London Times.
And I'm also very much a writing mentor to me.
Um,
but him,
he kept saying,
I don't want to have kids.
I only want to have cats.
And,
um,
and he was perfectly happy to be with me for the rest of his life,
but without children.
And I was very clear that I wanted to have children.
Um,
so I made the decision to leave him and because I didn't trust myself not to go
back to him if I had stayed in London,
I left London and moved to New York.
So everything that happened to me after that,
um,
my,
the rest of my work,
I'm launching the Huffington post to having my two daughters.
All of it team happened because a man wouldn't marry me and have children with
me.
So that's good.
Very [inaudible] that
well,
it's kind of like if you have insomnia at three in the morning,
right?
Maybe,
maybe it's a,
it's sort of a hard,
a hard moment,
uh,
an opportunity or a gift disguised as a very hard moment.
And,
uh,
the,
for those people who don't know,
how did the Huffington Post's come to Bsu land in New York?
How,
how did the Huffington post come to be?
Oh,
that's,
um,
the haven't been bossed is,
many,
many years after I land in New York.
So I was born in 1950,
so I'm 67.
I left London and in 1980 when I was 30 and moved to New York and then continued
writing,
you know,
written 15 books.
And after the book that he would discuss the female woman,
I wrote a book on political leadership called after reason,
which nobody wanted to buy.
But that's another story.
And then I wrote biographies of Maria Callas and later Babbo Picasa.
So when I came to New York,
I had just published my biography of Maria Callas,
who is an opera singer,
best known among people who don't love opera as the woman who was
very much in love with Aristotle Onassis.
But our nurses,
laughter do married Jackie Kennedy.
Um,
just to put in context and,
uh,
so when I came to New York,
um,
my book and Maria Karla said,
just been published.
And,
uh,
so I was um,
which made it easier to move to New York because I was,
um,
I was here,
publicizing my book the book down.
That would be a big best seller.
And um,
any glad to eh,
my doing journalists,
men writing more books.
Why buy now moving and living in New York,
how 15 books is a lot of books.
What is your writing process or what helps you to be so prolific?
I'm always impressed and have been impressed when I've considered how many books
you've written,
uh,
what,
what helps you to achieve that type of volume?
Okay.
So my am writing process changed dramatically.
Um,
at the beginning,
um,
my writing process was painstaking and incredibly slow because,
I had this sort of inner Sansar so I would write a sentence and then they enter
sensor would step in and say,
that's not the right word.
And I would,
um,
spend a long time arguing with myself about what the right word was.
And then
gradually I realized that I was able to speak without notes for an hour longer
and that I should use that skill to create first drafts.
So I started,
um,
dictating my first draft idea lead to somebody I work with that I,
because I like having that kind of response from someone.
If you're in the same room and you are speaking and they're typing,
um,
but you,
you kind of this mylar Gfo or they they show whether they liked or didn't like
something.
And um,
and that has dramatically accelerated my writing process because it's so much
easier as you know,
team to add it a first draft and edited extensively and go through multiple
editing,
editing processes than it is to write a first draft.
And is the,
is the person your speaking to interacting with you or asking you questions or
are they just listening and transfers?
Just listening.
I mean,
you know that that baffling free to interrupt and say anything,
but largely it's just listening,
but just kind of,
you know how people listen,
but they,
they show you if they get,
if they agree or if they liked something or they didn't get it.
It's like it's,
it's very sad.
Low but obvious.
Oh,
for sure.
I mean,
you can see that's,
that's one thing I always pay attention to when I have proofreaders reading my
material.
I like to be there when they read it because if they laugh,
I always say,
okay,
what was that?
And they'll say,
oh no,
it was nothing.
And I'm like,
no,
no.
What was it?
What made you laugh?
I always want to know what provokes the response.
Yes,
no,
I asked about the,
the interaction,
because I remember with the four hour work week in particular,
I hit a point where I was really stuck and I was stuck,
not for a day,
but for about two weeks and I didn't know how to tackle this chapter.
So I decided to,
I had the intention of having someone interview me so they could ghost write a
first draft that I could then use as a jumping off point.
But I,
I learned as they interviewed me over the course of about 90 minutes that they
had actually helped me figure out how to fix the chapter just by interviewing me
because I was too close to the material.
Some.
I'm really fascinated by using those types of tools to a jumpstart or like you
said,
to get a first draft out because that is so difficult at times.
Right.
I'm glad to hear that you,
you have a kind of similar process.
Yeah.
The interviewing I find is a great way to take a step back from the material I
never give.
If I need someone to interview me to,
to figure out a given chapter or aspect of a book,
I,
I never give them any background because I want them to come in fresh,
like a reader who just picked it up off the shelf without any type of any type
of context.
Uh,
so the,
you're writing in working on all these books,
when was the decision made to turn the Huffington post into a company or to
create that company?
So,
um,
by 2000,
I started seeing that a lot,
very rich conversation was moving online and that a lot of the people I loved
and admired,
we're not going to be part of it because they were never going to start a blog.
And because,
um,
at the time,
you know,
bloggers were seen as people who couldn't get a job and we're blogging,
remember the cliche from their parents' basement.
Right,
right.
And,
uh,
so I started writing in my column.
I had a call and we syndicated column at the time about bloggers and,
um,
and uh,
I just really loved this,
uh,
um,
what blogging was,
which just being more conversational,
being Marty demand,
responding to your readers,
they're respond back,
the whole interactive nature.
So I,
um,
decided together with my cofounder candy lab to launch the haven't done passed
in 2005,
um,
who I see as two things.
One was a collection of,
and bloggers.
I'm commenting on anything from the events of the day to food,
to a movies,
anything at all.
I mean,
one of I was saying was if you have something to say,
say it on the Huffington Post.
And I'm also a journalistic enterprise where we practiced conventional
journalism,
investigative journalism.
At the beginning,
the blogging part was the dominant part until we started raising,
raising and making money to be able to hire journalists.
And,
uh,
the first day we launched it,
well,
it's kind of a new day for blogging because suddenly we had,
we had on our front page and people like Nora Ephron and Walter Cronkite and
John Cusack and Larry David and people were never blogged before.
And it began the process of elevating blogging,
do something that of course,
now we all do.
There's no journalist who isn't blogging at the same time.
And,
um,
and gradually we started adding journalists who ended up winning a Pulitzer for
investigative journalists.
Men from the beginning,
I saw huffpost as a combination of the best of the old and the best of the new.
How did you get all of those,
uh,
known names to participate during the lunch?
What did you,
what did you say to them or how did you convince,
how did you convince them to do that?
So what kind of people I had met and I wrote to them and basically my peach was,
you wake up in the morning and you have something to say.
I know you do about the events of the day,
about a movie you saw last night about anything and,
but you're busy.
You have a book to write.
Do you have a company to run?
Um,
and you know,
sure you could write it for the New York Times,
but you have to deal with editors and processes and you don't really bother.
Just send it to us and put it in an email and send it to me and we'll publish it
exactly as you sent it to us.
And you will have entered the cultural bloodstream.
You'll have entered the conversation and you don't have to do anything else.
Then people can come and react,
take it to the next level.
And it was amazing.
That's exactly what happened.
I remember,
um,
I remember when,
the day that it was revealed who deep throat was,
I don't know if you remember that team or if you were still in kindergarten.
So yeah,
I'm aware of it,
but I don't want to say I remember it because maybe I wasn't kindergarten,
but I'm not sure.
He does actually in 2005.
Yeah,
there we go.
Then I was a few years after kindergarten,
so,
um,
and Nora Ephron called me and said,
listen,
everybody wants me to comment on that.
The New York Times asked me to write about it.
CNN wants me to go speak about it because she was at the time married to Carl
Bernstein and everybody wanted to know,
did she know,
why did she think,
etc. But she said,
you know what,
I'm instead going to write it for the Huffington Post.
And she did.
It was a big moment for us.
Why did she choose to do that?
Um,
she and I were friends.
She believed in what I was doing and um,
and she was Nora Ephron and she wanted to try new things.
And as she said,
I don't want to put makeup on and go to CNN
and a,
and I'm writing another book and I don't want to spend time arguing with New
York Times editors about a sentence,
right?
I want to spend 20 minutes write this down and you publish it.
And,
but what was amazing team was what happened afterwards because Nora Ephron's
piece was everywhere.
It was in the New York Times and it was on CNN.
And suddenly people began to realize I did no longer mattered.
Whoever you wrote something,
if it was interesting or newsworthy or important in some way or another,
it would be everywhere.
So I want to,
I'm going to pick that up in a second,
but you see,
as you were recalling the rough pitch that you gave to these people and you
mentioned entering the cultural bloodstream.
So I've seen you in action talking to people,
brainstorming ideas,
suggesting ideas,
and you're a,
you're a very,
very good at pitching and persuading.
Where did you pick that up?
Is that from debate or is it from something else?
Are there other ways that you developed that skill because you're very good at
it?
I think for me,
Eh,
persuasion is about seeing what does the other person want.
Um,
I mean,
you remember you are now we're at the dinner,
um,
a month ago and um,
there was,
um,
famous designer that we will not mention his name.
And um,
as you know,
I believe that it's great if people were dedicated sleep wow.
When they go to sleep,
unless they like to sleep naked because it kind of rekindles the romance with
sleep and it makes it clear to their brains and they're going to sleep.
So I thought it would be great to get a,
a big designer designing not just clothes but sleepwear.
But he had already told me that he liked breaking rules and doing things
differently.
And so for me,
when I pitch the idea of designing sleepwear,
I knew what the opening was that he,
that he liked to break conventions and do things differently and that he was
asking his team to do the same.
So then that would be a really fun conversation.
And we are talking about him designing sleepwear,
but for me,
the keys to find out what is the common point of what I'd like to see happen and
what the other person would like to see happen.
So if you,
if you,
I mean do you have a very good portfolio of skills for many of the things that
you've ended up building?
And if you were,
for instance,
teaching a wet,
you can choose the year,
let's just call it either freshman year in college or senior year in college,
you're teaching a seminar and it's a small group of students,
let's call it 20 students and you're trying to get them ready for professional
life or business life.
What would you focus on teaching them in this seminar?
Let's just say it's once per week.
You've two to three hours with them.
For us for a single semester.
What would you,
what would you teach?
What would you focus on?
Oh,
right now I would absolutely focus on them prioritizing their own human capital.
A lot of people think that success is about what we get from the outside,
but the truth is that success is so based on what we can create,
um,
from what we have inside us and how we can access that place of creativity and
resilience and peace inside us.
I'm so convinced of that now and um,
and it's getting harder and harder because the distractions,
um,
the invasiveness of technology are so overwhelming.
So I don't think there's anything more important.
Um,
it helps you come up with the best ideas.
It helps you not burn out,
which makes you more resilient in terms of facing knows and failure.
So that would definitely be my seminar.
And what,
what tools or suggestions or practices would you try to impart to these
students?
Because let's just say if we're talking about Cambridge,
they've,
they've almost pre qualify.
It already is type a personalities probably,
right?
I mean,
these are very ambitious kids.
Uh,
so what would you,
are there any particular tools or philosophies or books or anything that you
would recommend to them to,
uh,
armed them away for defending against burnout later?
Yes.
I,
I would recommend that they read the latest science around the importance of
sleep and pauses in the course of our day because we claim to be data driven,
eh,
but in fact we're living our lives ignoring the data and the prep,
the prevailing culture still believes that,
uh,
um,
being always on is the way to succeed.
Um,
that,
uh,
cutting down on sleep means we are more productive because,
because we have more time available.
So I would show them the latest science and then I would bring together new role
models,
people in the arena that they admire.
And if they admire business people,
people like Jeff Bezos who wrote on thrive global,
why he gets eight hours of sleep a night as he put it,
it's good for Amazon shareholders because,
and he broke it down.
He said,
when I get six hours,
my decision making is five to 20% less good.
Then when I've had eight hours and my value is entirely dependent on the quality
of my decisions.
Now that's entirely based on science and not his personal observation of how he
makes decisions or if people are more likely to be swayed by cultural icons.
I would a quad Selena Gomez who wrote for us,
why is she does a regular digital detox because as she put it,
when she does a digital detox,
she reconnects with herself and is much more present in everything she's doing
in her life.
What does a digital detox look like for her or for anyone else who might want to
try it?
Well,
people can pick their own way of doing it,
but it's basically taking,
it could be anything from a day and we can.
Um,
and now I away from our phones.
Thich Nhat Hanh said it's never easier to run away from ourselves.
Um,
the human attention span is now shorter than the hue.
Then the attention span of the Goldfish,
it's down to eight seconds.
So anything we can do that,
um,
helps us disconnect from the distractions,
reconnect with ourselves,
whatever form it takes.
I'm a big believer in micro steps.
Like if the idea of a one day digital detox is overwhelming,
just try it out,
try half an hour,
whatever.
Um,
whatever your entry point is,
just take it.
So what out of mentioned a few maybe micro steps that I've found helpful for
myself,
then I'd love to hear some of yours because I've noticed for myself at least at
that I always put my phone on airplane mode,
uh,
after typically after dinner and it stays in airplane mode until I've meditated
the next morning.
Uh,
that is what
one practice
and I've
been doing that for probably two years now.
Uh,
because I've noticed that if,
if I do not have it on airplane mode,
number one,
there will be lights and so on in my bedroom,
which is not ideal.
And I,
I know that you have quite a bit to say on that.
And I also find that if,
if I am barraged by any type of inputs in the morning before doing my
meditation,
the meditation is of a very,
very low quality.
And,
uh,
the second thing that I do on a weekly basis is I try to take what I would call,
what I do call a screen free Saturdays.
And it doesn't mean that I'm totally avoiding electronics because I will,
I don't own a car currently and I'll use my phone for say Uber or Google maps
and so on.
But otherwise I'm not using a laptop and I'm not using social media of any type.
So on Saturdays that is a weekly sort of Sabbath,
uh,
away from a lot of the distractions.
Are there any other micro steps that you might recommend to people or that you
found personally?
That's fantastic
and I know how many people have been influenced by you doing that.
Um,
for me,
uh,
another little micro step is not charging our phone by a bed.
And the reason for that is that we are all slightly addicted to our phones and
even with the best intentions,
if we wake up in the middle of the night and we can't easily go back to sleep
and our phone is right by her bed,
we are going to be tempted to pick up the phone and um,
and look at our tech.
So look at Instagram and that will dramatically interfere who is the,
our ability to go back to sleep and to recharge.
So,
um,
that's one little micro step.
Um,
and other micro step for me,
um,
which is similar to yours is never rushing into my phone.
Um,
at the beginning of the of the morning,
the first thing I do but have my own ritual,
which includes meditation,
um,
and which includes,
uh,
setting my intention for the day before I get on my phone.
And when I get on,
I love doing my stationary bike in the morning.
I'm perfectly fine being on my phone and answering emails while on the bike.
What is a black sheep?
I'm going to ask you about your morning routine and then I'm going to come back
to why all of this became so important to you.
But what is your morning look like?
Do you have any particular routines that,
could you walk us through the first say 90 minutes of your day when you wake up
and then what happens after that?
So,
um,
first of all,
I just wanted to say that the,
I,
I don believe,
uh,
in having at the same time to go to sleep at night and the same time to wake up
in the morning kind of my life doesn't work like that and I don't like setting
up rules,
which I'm going to break every day.
So I,
my goal now is to wake up eight hours after I went to sleep.
And because I have found out that eight hours is what I need to operate on
optimally.
And,
um,
also it happens to be,
quite a lot of people in need.
You know,
the most scientists have told us that unless you have a genetic mutation and
which case you can do great on three or four hours and about one and a half
percent of the population has that the rest of us need seven to nine hours to,
um,
to have a fully restorative sleep.
So that's kind of my,
my ground rule to myself.
And 95% of the time I do it.
I,
I'm,
I don't do anything perfectly and I'm a work in progress,
but I think 95% is pretty good.
So you wake up eight hours,
let's say after you've gone to bed and then what happens after that?
And then I am,
the first thing I do is sort of meditate and said,
and then after my meditation,
I said my denture for the day.
Like,
what,
uh,
what is,
what do I want out of that day in terms of my work or my being or my family?
And the reason why I think it's so important is because I used to just go
straight to my phone or my laptop.
And,
uh,
that's what the world wants of us,
right?
It's every male and every text.
And,
and I feel it's very important for us to be clear about what we want because you
can't really run your life from your inbox.
No.
Well,
as a friend of mine who actually,
he put this to me and he learned it from someone else who's a billionaire who
said to him,
you know,
that your inbox is everyone else's agenda for your time.
I love that.
And that's a very good way to think about it because it's extremely reactive.
Uh,
and uh,
you seem to have very proactive programming in a way.
And,
uh,
you do seem to have certain routines or rituals.
I'd love to talk about.
Uh,
and this,
this will tie into a lot of what we're talking about walking.
Could you,
because I've read in doing research for our conversation that one of your
favorite phrases,
and I'm going to mess this up because this looks like Latin is sold,
the tour [inaudible] it,
which means it is solved by walking.
Could you please talk about walking and what role it has in your life?
So,
um,
you know,
I lived in Los Angeles for many years.
I,
um,
my two daughters went to school there and then I lived in Brentwood and it's
kind of amazing hikes everywhere.
Literally five minutes in the car from my home.
They're the most beautiful hikes,
the Mandeville Canyon Chi hike and they cantor hike.
And so I got into the habit of having all my meetings.
I'm quote unquote lunches,
etc. With friends during hikes.
So instead of going for a lunch or a meeting with friends,
we would go on a hike and a,
the one was in better shape.
We'll talk on the way up and they,
one was in worse shape.
We'll talk on the way down.
And um,
some of the best things happened on these hikes.
Um,
I remember telling all my girlfriends about,
um,
my idea of launching the Huffington post and Laurie David,
who at the time was married to Larry David immediately said,
I'll invest.
In fact,
Laurie and Laurie invested together and then when they got divorced,
they split the investment.
And um,
and Kimberly Brooks became my first,
um,
art editor.
And it was just like a great way to just talk about everything,
whether it was work or personal life.
Um,
there was something about being in nature that made us all more willing to be
authentic and vulnerable.
And I'm still,
now when I get to La,
I,
I see my friends on hikes or walks around the block or whatever we have time
for.
But I love it.
And of course now being in New York,
it's fantastic because I can walk everywhere.
It's a great walking city.
New York is really a fantastic walking city.
And I've,
I've noticed a number of my,
what I would consider most productive friends,
which is saying a lot because a lot of productive friends,
but for instance,
uh,
naval Ravikant who's really a very soulful and intelligent person who's been on
this podcast before,
uh,
does walk and talk meetings.
So he'll have someone come and meet him.
This isn't San Francisco and it might just be a walk around several blocks and
doing a few laps of that route.
But,
uh,
he will do walk and talk in that way.
And I've also noticed that a few of my friends who I would also put in that top
performing category,
they'll do walk and talks,
but they'll do it with video,
facetime,
uh,
so that they can look at the other person as they're walking,
which I thought was quite clever.
Uh,
well actually walking meetings is another great thing to do and we do a lot of
it here at thrive,
especially if it's one on one,
it gets harder navigating the streets of New York if it's more than two people,
but you can do it up to three and then it gets really hard.
What,
uh,
what,
if you don't mind,
and this will perhaps lead us into thrive,
but what were,
could you talk about one of the harder or darker periods during the,
the,
the Huffington Post,
Huffington,
yours,
and what helped you to get out of it?
Uh,
and just walk us through maybe a story of one of those times because I think
that it's very easy for people listening to this podcast to put the people being
interviewed on a pedestal and assume they've always had everything figured out
and they just step up to the plate and always hit home runs.
But is there any particular tough period or time at Huffington Post that you
could tell us about and what helped you to get through it or get out of it?
Yeah.
Yes,
absolutely.
And I'm so glad you're focusing on that because the worst thing we can do is
give people the delusion that,
uh,
um,
everything has been plain sailing for me.
The hardest time was that two years into building half-past when,
um,
I was,
I'm literally working around the clock.
I also had two daughters who at the time we're teenagers and,
um,
that's probably the hardest time for a mother and her teenage daughters.
And,
uh,
I was divorced so I was bringing them up on my own and my oldest daughter was,
um,
at the time when we did the college tours to decide what college she was going
to go.
Um,
and basically what would happen,
she had made that rule who just very legitimate,
no blackberries.
It was blackberry time and when we're together.
So she and I would be together going from college to college during the day and
then at night to check into a hotel,
she would go to sleep and I would start working.
So I got back to Los Angeles and I was completely exhausted without even
realizing I was completely exhausted and running on empty until I got up from my
desk that first morning back.
Yeah.
Because I was feeling called to get a sweater and I collapsed and he had my head
on my desk,
broke my cheekbone,
that first teachers on my ride or die.
And that was the beginning of the journey that led to the thrive book and the
Sleep Revolution Book and the Thrive Company.
Um,
at the time it was a very dark time.
because first of all,
when something like that happens and nobody knows what's wrong with you,
do you have a brain tumor?
Um,
do you have a hard problem?
So does literally two weeks of going from doctor to doctor from Mri to
electrocardiogram to check what was wrong with me.
And at the end of this two weeks,
um,
I,
I feel it,
this was a movie I would have had all the doctors in one room in the white
coats,
basically give me the diagnosis is,
Ariana,
you are suffering from civilization's disease,
burnout and there's nothing we can do for you.
You have to change your life.
And um,
and it really took that painful wake up call for me to realize that I had to
change my life.
And that's why now I'm,
I feel such an evangelist about this topic because I feel people can make
incremental changes in their lives before they hit the proverbial wall.
And what is finally Tim,
is that if you had asked me that morning,
Arianna,
how are you?
I would have said fine because I had forgotten what being fine really was.
Yeah.
You get it,
you know,
being like perpetually tired had become the new normal and um,
and I had literally forgotten it so much so that,
uh,
I wasn't even aware of the fact that I was running on empty.
So I'm really glad we're talking about this and I just want to reflect on one
thing you said,
which is how you would've said you were fine because you'd forgotten what normal
actually was.
Uh,
I remember a few years ago I hit a point of,
of burnout,
complete burnout,
uh,
right after,
during,
and then right after the four hour chef for many reasons,
but I won't bore everybody with them right now.
And what I ended up doing after that as,
as part of my attempt to recover,
was agreeing to do my first meditation retreat of it was only two or three days.
And there were a number of rules.
Rule number one was you can't use an alarm clock and if you need to sleep and
that's all you do this weekend,
then that's what you do.
And I felt like that was going to be a huge waste because I knew I was tired,
but that was part one.
And part two was they recommended that everyone cut back on caffeine intake,
which,
uh,
is my,
I suppose one of my,
uh,
compounds of choice.
Fortunately,
I'm not drawn to opiates,
but a stimulants are,
uh,
unfortunately,
something that has,
have,
have often been right at my side and my body just seems to crave and respond to
that with a certain degree of addiction.
So I had been in my normal routine for months prior to that going to a Thai
restaurant that would let me sit down and work on my book and they would give me
the unending cup or glass of ice tea.
So it ended up drinking two or three gallons probably of ice tea and that,
and that was my normal,
right.
So that's just what I assumed baseline felt like.
And then for the first time in probably six months,
I went completely off of caffeine in preparation for this retreat.
Uh,
proceeded to sleep almost the entire weekend and,
uh,
I felt rejuvenated.
No gadgets or devices.
Then I went back to,
in this case,
San Francisco where I used to live and what did I do?
I went back into my routine and I went to the Thai restaurant and then I
remember after maybe two or three glasses of ice tea and keeping in mind that
before that I was drinking 2030 not feeling anything that was just status quo
and I had maybe three glasses and I felt so agitated and so unpleasant that I
realized,
oh my God,
like this times 10 was what I assumed was normal just a week or two ago.
And it was just mind boggling.
I mean it was,
it was such a wake up call for me.
Uh,
but if I feel like I'm giving a confessional,
I just wanted to share that.
But what were some of the first things that you did after you hit your head?
Saw these doctors,
they say you need to change your life in the say week that followed.
What did you do?
Well,
first of all,
I love your story because it's the same message that we,
we both want to impart,
which is how often we're not even aware of what we're doing to ourselves.
And that's why by listening to each other's stories,
we can and increase our own awareness.
So for me that,
that first of all,
this past two weeks who I spent going to doctors and asking questions,
um,
you know,
I've always been drawn to philosophy.
I always loved
reading the Greeks and the Romans and everyone in between.
And the,
the one question that really every philosopher asks is,
what is a good life?
And I feel that what we've done is you reduce the answer to that question too.
What is,
um,
what is success?
And it will reduce the good life to a successful life.
And we reduced success down to money and power slash status.
So if kind of shrunk and the definition of a good life.
And,
um,
and I found that during that time I went back to books I loved and had read
before.
So it's not as if there's just like a new journey for me.
I'd always been drawn
to that question,
but this was something that had a new urgency and I knew,
um,
determination to actually live differently and not just read great books.
And were there any particular changes?
You,
were there any particular books you remember,
uh,
having a renewed impact on you and then were there any particular steps that you
took after that?
Yes,
actually,
a book that I read that I had not read before,
um,
which was recommended by a friend was incredibly
powerful for me because it was written by a man who was in the arena and yet
lived life the way I wanted to live my life.
And that was mark was a realia
meditations.
Meditations.
Exactly.
So he was the ambassador of row and that is a pretty big job.
He,
um,
he had faced,
invasions and plagues and betray Alison,
an unfaithful wife.
And yet he was able to be imperturbable.
That was my favorite word at the time.
And,
and be very connected to that centered place in himself from which he wrote this
amazing book called Meditations.
And,
um,
I love that because,
you know,
it's easy to read books by Buddhist monks and,
uh,
Miss Jan mistakes and,
and you want,
I wanted to hear from somebody who was in the arena,
right?
Someone who's on the front lines actually having to deal with the difficulties
and messiness of the real world.
Yes.
And,
and,
uh,
I don't,
I'm not suggesting that my life was anything like mark was a realtor says life.
But nevertheless,
I was in the arena.
I,
I had to deal with the daily challenges of life and work and,
and,
uh,
there was one quote in fact,
which I have laminated and carry with me that I love so much in the book and it
goes as follows.
People look for it treats for themselves in the country,
by the coast or in the hills.
There is no way that a person can find a more peaceful and trouble free retreat
and in his own mind.
So constantly give yourself this retreat and renew yourself.
That is a great quote.
That is a really,
really,
really great quote.
I don't think,
I'm amazed we haven't talked about this.
There were only talking about Marcus really,
and I'm not going to go off on a crazy stoic
sidetracked.
Oh,
I also have a quote from meditations and I tend to be a Seneca guy,
which is,
is controversial,
but he's a beautiful writer and,
and people very often when they are,
if they get bitten by the bug of stoic philosophy,
tend to go say to Marcus,
really a spore.
Seneca,
ah,
often liked both.
And then there's a,
I'd say maybe 10% who love epic,
tedious for any number of reasons,
but there's,
there's this quote from an I,
I don't recall it exactly because it's actually on my refrigerator and I'm not
near my refrigerator.
But in effect it says when you are taken away from the harmony,
you to do what you can to return to it as easily as possible or as effortlessly
as possible.
And it is,
it's to,
was a reminder to me that it's,
it's not so much the goal to never be off balance.
It's to regain your balance.
Oh,
I love that.
I couldn't agree more.
In fact,
it is impossible to always be in that centered place.
There's no human being on earth that I have ever met.
Um,
maybe there's some enlightened,
sane somewhere who can be in that centered place all the time.
So you're absolutely right.
It's all about how quickly can we course correct.
Now you mentioned the arena and you have certainly been in the arena in many
different ways,
uh,
in,
in the,
in your lifetime.
So far in a no doubt you will continue to be in the arena because I think you
enjoy the full contact sport of it.
Uh,
I wanted to ask you a question about hiring at thrive and uh,
this,
what I'm about to read comes from a piece in ink magazine and I'd just love to
hear you either fact check it and just correct it or elaborate on it.
Because of course,
quotes are not always accurate on the Internet,
but,
uh,
sometimes they are.
So what it says is now during interviews,
there's a speech I give to everybody and this is quoting you.
And the,
the speech is something like this,
uh,
for potential new hires.
I give you full permission to walk into my office and scream at me.
But I want you to consider this as my last warning.
If you complain about any of your colleagues behind their backs,
uh,
would be let go.
It does make,
and then you go on to comment on how it makes a difference.
When you tell people this,
I had never known this,
but can you,
can you tell us more about,
uh,
whether this is accurate and then what the speech is and why you give it.
So,
um,
I really believe that we are moving away from what is seen as traditional HR
practice,
which is you go and complain to HR about a colleague.
Hr goes to the colleague and says,
somebody's not naming who complained about them.
And,
uh,
and it becomes this like the kind of game shrouded in secrecy that creates a
very toxic environment.
And I believe where HR is moving to now and suddenly this is what we both
practice and teach in a,
in the work we're doing with corporations is a authentic transparency.
And,
um,
I believe that people who trust themselves
and trust each other are willing to have difficult conversations.
You know,
relationships are not easy.
Whether their work relationships or personal relationships or may upset each
other.
We may say something the other person takes the wrong way.
Who may do something that upset someone.
I give everybody complete permission started with me to come and tell me
directly that I did something that didn't,
like I said some they didn't like.
And when I say scream,
I want to make the point that say it in as Roy away as you want.
You don't have to figure it out.
How to say do you don't have to.
You can say it while you are angry,
don't have,
you don't have to wait to calm down,
whatever.
But if you are incapable of doing that,
if you are only capable of passive aggressive behavior,
which is always being nice,
um,
do your managers or do your colleagues while bad mouthing them behind their
backs?
Consider this your last warning.
I mean if we say that as clearly as we have said it and not adjust I,
but everybody here,
but you are,
but you can't do it,
then this is not the right place for you.
I love that.
I wish more people did this.
Uh,
because I feel like,
and a,
I don't want to,
I'm trying to hold myself back.
I've had too much caffeine maybe,
but,
uh,
I feel like the handling of everyone with kid gloves and the sort of
infantilizing of the workplace is in the short term the avoidance of pain,
but guaranteed to create much larger problems and much greater pain in the
longterm.
So this approach I think is just so refreshing.
And my question is how do you,
uh,
when you are hiring people,
and many of those hires I would imagine are younger,
perhaps they've been,
they've only known the environment where you would go to HR and report.
They're not true.
They're not accustomed to having uncomfortable conversations with coworkers
where they tried to address things directly.
Do you,
do you try to in any way coach them or provide them with guidelines,
uh,
for how to have those conversations?
Oh yes,
absolutely.
In fact,
actually team,
it's interesting.
We hire a lot of people straight out of college and that's great.
It's so easy to tell them that and they get it.
And they practice it.
It's people who come to us from other companies,
um,
that need more coaching.
And,
um,
and I think we are able to do it by often having difficult conversations at our
leadership meetings.
I'm repeating that in our team meetings,
m ever repeating that again and again.
And that we encourage people to have difficult conversations.
We encourage people to communicate when they are not happy with something.
I always prioritize that people know,
if anybody texts me or emails me and says,
I have a problem.
Something has happened,
I want to talk to you.
I drop everything to address it.
So people know there's always a follow,
um,
including with me who are,
they can address problems.
And so I think we've,
um,
we've really created that,
that atmosphere and that space here.
And we also make it part of hiring.
So,
which helps hire people who are more comfortable having difficult conversations.
Now your,
your sister,
who else
has said that you are like Athena?
I believe.
Uh,
but,
uh,
on the flip side,
I've also read that your favorite Greek God is now,
I don't know if it's,
if you'd pronounce it Hermes or Air Maze,
is unless you want to refer to the scarves,
the scarves,
right?
It,
which confuses me as a long island boy with no culture.
So,
alright.
Hermes.
So why does she think that you're like Athena?
And why is your favorite Greek?
God Hermes?
Well,
first of all,
you know,
wrote a book on Greek gods and goddesses and,
um,
the where I approached them as archetypes and,
and I believe that we all carry all the gods and goddesses.
Inas um,
so the question is who is the most dominant God?
So I think that is,
um,
the goddess of wisdom.
And I'm,
I'm very Florida that my sister thinks that's my dominant goddess,
but I aspire to ham is being my dominant God because he's like my favorite God
of Greek mythology.
Um,
because he saw multifaceted.
He's both childlike and wise.
He's,
I'm a mystic and comfortable in the market place.
Um,
and,
uh,
he represents everything I love about our humanity in his very godlike way.
So he is my favorite.
And,
uh,
ab do you,
you really have had struck me in all of our interactions and as I've observed
you as someone who's really made a conscious effort,
as you said,
to be honest with yourself and,
uh,
to see reality as it is.
But there's,
there's one anecdote which I think falls into this category.
It's kind of related.
I think that,
uh,
I've never heard from you.
So again,
I,
I read a lot on the Internet and I have to be careful sometimes with that,
but did you have a conversation with Henry Kissinger about your accent at one
point and a,
and if so,
can you please tell the story
so you're not my,
um,
I've been very conscious of my accent for a long time and I am,
I did try to change it.
In fact,
um,
my ex husband gave me as a birthday gift,
which you may consider a very passive aggressive birthday gift,
a dialect coach for two weeks to follow me around and give me notes.
And it wasn't just any dialect coach.
She does Jessica Drake,
who is a very famous Hollywood dialect coach who coached forest Gump,
coach Tom Hanks in Forrest Gump.
And anyway,
so she literally followed me around at the time my children were young,
she would put this symbols on Dr Seuss books.
So when I was reading to my children,
I could practice and she would pull the lifesavers and my tongue,
so would pronounce my long like long these and my short,
it's like shards.
And by the end of it,
I was paralyzed.
I knew exactly what I was doing wrong,
but I could not really be inauthentic,
functioning,
human being and speak proper English.
So I gave up ever reluctant Lee,
um,
the harp of having pro speaking the Queen's English.
And soon after I gave up my husband though they do things aren't,
we're not related.
Um,
and then around that time I was talking to Henry Kissinger and I told him,
you know,
you're so comfortable with your accent and I've been so uncomfortable with it.
And he said,
Arianna,
give it up.
Uh,
in American public life,
you can never overestimate the advantages of complete and total
incomprehensibility.
Okay.
So you,
you learned to embrace it.
Was it,
was it easy?
I mean,
after that conversation,
was it easy or what was the,
I think it was a combination of,
um,
seeing how I could never speak.
Like Jessica Drake wanted me to speak unless I kind of measured every word and
lost all spontaneity.
And,
uh,
also the fact that Hendrick issues seem so completely comfortable with his heavy
German accent.
And now honestly,
I don't think about it,
but for a long time it really weighed on me.
Well,
you know,
I wanted to hear you tell that story,
which I,
I really only knew a tiny piece of it,
so I'm glad you told the full story and uh,
because I think you were very,
you live life very proactively and it's been inspiring to watch in our
interactions and also as I see you,
uh,
converse and interact and help other people.
So I really encourage people obviously to check out thrive global and uh,
I'll,
I'll mention in a second where they can find you on various social platforms.
But first and foremost,
I just wanted to thank you for,
for taking the time because this has been so fun and I'm sure we only
found the very tip of the iceberg in terms of the stories that you can tell.
Uh,
so maybe we'll do around two sometime,
but I,
I really appreciate you making the time to have the conversation.
Oh,
team.
I absolutely loved it.
Loved it.
And um,
I would love to invite your listeners to tell their own stories.
You know,
there are stories of burnout.
The wake up calls their life hacks and um,
we can pass them on your side and on thrive global and social them.
I really believe that our stories can help others in a way that goes beyond
science and data.
So I love collecting these stories and I love inviting people to participate.
Well,
let's,
let's point them to thrive global.com people should check it out.
Absolutely.
Check it out,
man.
I'm trying to make it even easier.
I'm going to give you my email address and they can email me directly.
That's how they're having done past started,
remember?
Okay.
So before you do that,
Derek Sivers once did that because he said no one's lifts listening after two
and a half hours and he had his inbox explode to the point that it became very
difficult to manage.
Is there a so I'll leave it up to you.
Okay.
All right.
Then
age@thriveglobal.com.
Alright.
So,
alright,
well you seem to be a masterful surfer of technology so I will,
I will leave you to contend with what comes out of it,
but everybody heard it.
A h@thriveglobal.com so you can send your stories to Ariana and you can just say
hello to her on Linkedin.
Arianna Huffington,
Facebook,
also Huffington,
and then Twitter and Instagram.
Ariana hough,
h u.
F.
Is there anything else,
Arianna,
in terms of asks or suggestions or parting comments that you'd like to make
before we finish up?
No,
that's my ask.
Let's share our stories and uh,
change the culture.
So we can reduce all the unnecessary suffering people are experiencing.
Thank you Tim,
so much for all you are doing to make that possible.
Well,
thank you for sharing so much and doing what you do and uh,
I'm absolutely thrilled to have you on and for everyone listening you can find
links to everything we've talked about in the show notes as usual at
tim.blog/podcast.
Ariana,
thank you so much and to everyone listening,
be safe,
get your sleep and pay attention to your body and how you feel and as always,
thank you
for listening.
Hey guys,
this is Tim again.
Just a few more things before you take off.
Number one,
this is five bullet Friday.
Do you want to get a short email from me?
Would you enjoy getting a short email from me every Friday?
That provides a little more soul of fun before the weekend and five bullet
Friday is a very short email where I share the coolest things I've found or that
I've been pondering over the week.
That could include favorite new albums that I've discovered.
It could include Gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of weird shit that I've
somehow dug up in the other world of the esoteric as I do.
It could include favorite articles that I've read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance,
and it's very short.
It's just a little tiny bite of goodness before you head off for the weekend.
So if you want to receive that,
check it out.
Just go to four hour work week.com that's four hour work week.com all spelled
out and just drop in your email and you will get the very next one.
And if you sign up,
I hope you enjoyed,
this episode is brought to you by me undies.
I've spent the last few years wearing underwear from these guys,
24 seven or close to it outside of showers and sexy time and swimming and they
are the most comfortable and colorful underwear I've ever owned.
You should check out the camouflage boxer briefs.
I'm a big fan.
Me undies are designed in La and made from sustainably sourced Mike Rowe.
Madame,
what's that?
It is a fabric three times softer than cotton.
Trust me.
Try it out.
You'll understand why I rarely so much.
If underwear isn't your thing though,
I would imagine everyone wears under it,
but if it isn't your thing,
[inaudible] is also makes socks.
Their socks are spun from premium material,
making them just as comfortable as the underwear.
Now,
right now,
[inaudible] has an exclusive offer just for Tim Ferriss show listeners.
You can get 20% off your first order and free shipping,
so check it out.
Take a look.
Some of them are pretty Rad.
They have different cereals from your childhood on underwear and a lot more
[inaudible] dot com forward slash.
Tim Take a look me undies.com forward slash Tim they offer a 100% satisfaction
guarantee.
If you're unhappy with your purchase for any reason,
just send them back and you receive a full refund.
Again,
that's me,
undies.com forward slash Tim for 20% off and free shipping.
This episode is brought to you by fresh books,
man.
Oh Man.
Do a lot of listeners of this podcast and readers and mind love fresh books.
To the extent that I ended up meeting with the CEO not very long ago.
Why are they so popular?
Well,
they are the number one cloud accounting software designed exclusively for self
employed professionals.
That's many of you and used by more than 10 million people.
You can send invoices,
track your time and get paid very,
very quickly,
which suits the needs of a lot of freelancers.
I locked onto I preventative was and beyond.
You can't take pictures of receipts.
You can link your credit card and debit card so all the things you buy
automatically appear in your fresh books in the right category,
so on and so forth.
Makes taxes easy,
makes invoices easy,
it makes your life easier.
And also in fact they're recommended pdf.
They didn't ask me to read this part by the way.
They'd put the other pdf awhile back called breaking the time barrier.
Subtitle,
how to unlock your true earning potential so you can search for breaking the
time barrier.
A lot of people ask me,
how can I get a four hour work week with a service business?
And the story in that Ebook,
it's pdf is the short answer is really,
really good.
So I think you should also check that out.
So breaking the time error,
checking out,
but also why not test out freshbooks.
Claim your 30 day unrestricted free trial@freshbooks.com forward slash Tim and
Inter Tim Ferriss,
two r's and two s's in the,
how did you hear about us section?
That sounds like we're going to get very little tracking and it's a lot of work,
but just go to freshbooks.com forward slash Tim and try it out because it is a
very good product and I think you will find it simplifies your life.
Joy.
Okay.